hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood i just
cannot gush enough about this game
i just am so in love with it i don't
know what it is
and i don't know how to explain it fully
this door was open
either i left it open or someone was
there oh look at all the
rotten mushroom well i didn't know it
was i would have grab i didn't see it i
was in a bit of a hurry
oh diamonds i am so
gassed put these away put that in there
i didn't know it was there how'd i've
known it really wanted to give me the
upgrade but
apparently i bet in all these there's
just crap that
was good stuff let me let me let me
search the premises
actually look this time and not in a
panic sprint
lots of gas in here it's flooded with
gas
who the hell days are they assigning us
to us
who the hell are they assigning to us
[ __ ] off from the shack the whole
night he was rambling about some merrick
i think it's his younger brother or son
i don't know if he was the boredom or
the stress that got to him it was
[ __ ] unbearable he was the third
night in a row we tried to silence him
but it's [ __ ]
mush better not risk it i slid inside my
sleeping bag and zipped it shut i
preferred to suffocate in my own stencil
and listen to that [ __ ] go on and on
about it after a while i realized that m
is not there anymore he left around in
the morning he took all of his equipment
three liters of water sleeping bad radio
gun gasoline flamethrower his beloved
spitter and his lucky stone he only left
the hazard suit we're debating on
whether to report this no one's crazy
about running around the woods looking
for a psycho with a flamethrower
alright and more players which would
have been very useful
oh no no
oh there's a
generator genre there the whole time it
was right
right there that's okay that's okay
can i i can't cook these mushrooms at
all can i
nope they're just useless well if i'd
known about them i would i got here in a
bit of a panic
now they're just useless lumps of mush
great good
look at all these great goodies that's a
lot of great good goodies
okay that took forever to organize um
i'm going for a lateral organization
kind of like rough segments i don't know
it's not important but it was important
to me i need to sell some stuff to the
dude
i can probably get rid of one more
weapon part i need these on me
for one now well i guess now that i've
got my
ability that's really what that was for
i can afford to
probably cough up a couple of these and
this
um i'm out of booze where'd my
booze go did i drop my booze in a tizzy
somewhere
did i put my booze in the sawmill what
did i do i already have the welder so i
don't need another one
for now that'll do okay let's get down
to business we got a whole new area to
explore and i don't know what the hell
is going on so let's just trade potato
potato
tomato tomato pill pill antidote no room
in container
yeah you're right uh except perfect
750 smackers
that's a lot of smackers uh take the
weld or two and this antidote
okay i'm once again going to take the
wire i will take that axe blade now
not sure if it'll be better than the
shovel by the time i'm done with it but
i don't know i'll take your scrap metal
the mushroom yes the mush i'll take the
mush because that'll get that'll push me
over the edge
rags honestly i think boards just
because this new area is gonna need a
lot of crap
okay let me go ahead and cook that
mushroom see where i'm at and what other
new prize it's gonna give me
[Music]
oh oh i can scream at him once a day
i'll be able to scare off enemies
appetite i will be able to restore my
health by eating wood
well i haven't touched a single trap yet
so i think i'm okay i'll be able to eat
wood i'm gonna chomp on some wood
stamina gets low i'll do less damage in
combat
weak lungs well that sounds terrible i
will recover longer after exhausting
myself
does that mean after completely
exhausting yourself which i try to avoid
now
that wouldn't be too bad right maybe
weakness would be better
because i always hit with full stamina
anyway with the shovel the way it is
i think that weakness will be better
because i can't confirm that that's
completely
exhausting yourself oh no
not another vision i'd rather not i'd
rather not go to the other world
all right we're going i guess my wishes
are not respected in this environment
what i want doesn't matter
the smell of grass and trees yeah i've
been getting a lot of that lately
the earth bends under my footsteps the
sky swirls pleasantly
i doubt it i doubt it very much
i doubt it very much i think it's here
what's here
what oh
okay oh i wasn't expecting this
you look tired oh yeah you know you know
how it is
come lie with me feel the soil
the trees hung so calmly they sing so
beautifully
can you hear it no
oh you you i'm not gonna lie down
okay can you i can hear i can hear i can
you can't
you i will beat you up ha ha hey
you miss me you miss me miss me
ha miss me miss me
what no okay uh
i don't know what to do about this whole
conundrum
i don't know oh he got me right and my
tuck is around my butthole
i'm alive hello maybe i should have lied
down
hey did you see me go to another
dimension just there or was that just me
i'll take the axe blade yeah thank you
maybe one more small caliber magazine
okay thank you
thank you have a good day have a lovely
day i can eat wood now
that's my food of choice i'll just
remember to get back a little early
tonight to
pack up everything that i would need i
have good mouse grab metal i can
upgrade my shovel finally upgrade shovel
to
sturdy blade greatly increases weapon
durability
yes please thank you can't make the axe
yet but that's okay
i don't have enough for armor because no
mites i didn't get enough shell i sold
the other shell i didn't know that it
would get consumed like that but
hey whatever it's okay i don't need it
i'm never gonna get hit again
we're almost making this too easy i
guess i could see what the back end of
this is because if i can find a way to
go
through these areas might be good didn't
that guy say didn't he mark something on
the map for me
wasn't there the whole thing that he
marked something on the map he showed me
where it was
so i could find where my key would be
would do ain't that the thing that was
the
didn't he say something about that wait
eastern part of the old
woods so i just need to go east
almost too easy all right let's go bear
traps
it's dark i don't have a light i forgot
about light
ah crap almost making this too easy on
me i was gonna
take it easy on them because they are
making it so easy on me
gotta save some wood for myself to eat
it would almost be too easy oh wait just
i just
munch it why is it
probably because i'm turning into a tree
but whatever
that's where all this is going we're all
turning into trees
that's probably gonna explode
oh god where where where where where
where where
where where where is it where is it
where is it i'm not seeing oh god rain
perfect excellent timing
perfect hunter you
say howdy
any traps in here
i see traps hunter
suggests traps
oh hey bud there he is
okay well now that i know what i'm
facing should be no problem
i really could use the lantern oh yeah
here we go here we go here we go
there we go i missed me bonkers oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god
stop hitting me
stop hitting me oh my god oh my god oh
my god do not do not
hang on i need to stop i don't know why
i was able to dodge the thing in the
dream of
a bajillion times yet this guy
this guy seems to be giving me the
business
i'm going to give him the business this
ain't over [ __ ]
this ain't over [ __ ] where'd you go oh
god oh my god
there you go yeah yeah you want some
turns out that you can't have any
miss me that much
oh my god you're still alive oh god yeah
wish they would make this difference
dude
i knew that was there ah i knew it was
there i knew it was
god i knew that my god
i knew that was there i'm so stupid
wow wow wow
that was a lot of things okay hey can
you not
be bashing on that while i'm in here
working very rude very high
oh that's probably important
um okay
okay
i don't trust
oh i don't trust that not at all
okay photo don't like that
i don't know if i can even use the
fabric anymore and i don't know what the
toolbox is for
so there's that i don't trust that
oh trophy's missing a head
is there anything else in here that i
need to get or can i just let this one
go
mushrooms don't get up don't get up
don't get up don't get up don't get up
don't get up don't worry about it all
right see you around bud
have a good one you never
great man so many goodies so much fun
goodies
so many fun oh great so many things oh i
can make armor out of that
that's wonderful yay let me hang on let
me munch on this
put that right in there tasty
uh there's some kind of other room over
there but i i don't know how to
access that one oh it's it's open from
the outside i see
well i'm gonna go cook up these things
and maybe kill some out there let me
munch on this wood over here
why is that some wood oh my goodness i
was hungry
oh my god you oh you uh poochie
nope ah
okay thank you that was great let me
munch on some more
all wood cool destroy generator huh that
seems fun
this would almost make a good hideout i
guess this guy doesn't know how to
survive when a generator is down
unlike me almost made it too easy to
survive
almost too easy oh god
i would like to
run away hey
hey bud listen you don't want to be in
here this is a
weird different place
what are you gonna do you can't find me
idiot idiot what is he doing
what what the hell
ow ow ow ow okay
i don't trust it i don't trust it
good i good thing i didn't trust it
where's my wood meal
and chop up some wood boy i'm hungry
jumpy jumpy okay good this uh place is a
little
dangerous i can make some armor and i
definitely see the value of a lantern
i really truly see the value of a
lantern
oh i can make another hop bar upgrade
yes please excellent
i gotta let it do its thing i'll bring
it with me
a little snack for the road you know
i probably shouldn't because i'm gonna
need the wood for barricades but
man it's too fun how can you not put
this on my hot bar
let's crunch up some wood munch i can't
munch it oh i gotta
i can't actually munch it from there
fine
be that way this is a useless skill but
i love the idea
just the concept is so funny how could i
not oh dinner
what if i munch on a log oh my god you
can munch on a log
oh you can munch on a log no not that
way ah
good thing i got a log in me
hi you got poisoned ow
you got me good good good move
okay the log changes the dynamic a bit
because
munching on logs means that i don't have
to turn everything into
planks and i could just find good food
that's good yeah i imagine there's going
to be a lot more bear traps around here
just got to be mindful all right all
right all right
okay i feel pretty good about this
easy easy almost too easy
i'm just taking it super slow not gonna
be caught with my pants down
oh there's big egg
lap thanks thanks for the umbro
thanks for the mibrio don't know why the
mebrio was growing there but
thanks what is that
oh train wreck found the train wreck
trainwreck all the way do
this way okay i gotta get back soon
oh someone was camping there so is there
a way to get on this train or
is it just a cool landmark is there
anything
valuable to get from the train or is it
just
here no i guess it's just here
all right i got to get back because i
got to board up a lot of the house and i
got to make sure the generator's fueled
up which is going to take a little bit
of doing
ah interesting oh god oh god oh god okay
okay
okay that's fine hey
you want to dance i've been known to
tango pretty good
yeah the problem with the shovel on
those guys is they're too fast i'm
wondering if actually the
plank would be better to hit him with i
can't waste time
he's running away he didn't notice me oh
god i didn't even see the bear trap i
just moused over it
he's gonna notice me are you gonna
notice me
oh god where oh hello thank you
i will yes weapon parts
pills battery i'll come back for that or
i don't know if i need it
i don't know what it is for probably the
military grid flashlight that i sold
all right but now that i know that
there's a generator uh with plenty of um
oh let me go cook the stuff first before
i run out of everything
cook cook oh man i'm making tons of
progress
then i gotta go um put gas in the
generator and then button up a little
more
put that over there put that in there
scrap metal in
log that i can munch on if i really want
to but i'm gonna hold off
as tempting as it may be as delicious as
that log looks
i have to remember some of it's got to
go to construction
bam oh that's that's beautiful okay so i
don't think there's any point in def
like barricading much of these i mean i
i can't even rebuild a doorway there so
not much point in that um that's a gap
there so really all i'm trying to do is
i i guess i should rebuild this doorway
because there's a door up
there let's barricade this one yeah
cause
after that then i can just keep this one
blockaded
but open and leave this blockaded butt
open i think that should be fine let's
get my flares back out
just in case i could put down a bear
trap i guess
you know what why not right here
and then i'm gonna move this kind of
like block people off
[Music]
okay and then just dig in for the night
and there's another way that they can
come in over here but i don't think it's
gonna be too much of an issue
oh it's time okay
oh something's in
okay all right
all right try it
can't even figure out how to open a door
looks like you're about to get bear
trapped oh no
oh no womp okay
what the hell there oh my god okay
oh my god
jesus okay the shovel was the way to go
yeah shovel was definitely way to go oh
my god oh my god oh my god okay let's
um and let's switch over to shovel
where are you breaking oh god that's not
good
what if i hide can they find me oh god
oh no
oh no
[Music]
oh my god oh my god holy crap
oh my god how can i do this
okay no no no no not today
okay i'm gonna take a fast acting pill
whoa okay oh my god oh my god what is
that
what the hell is that put a flare up
oh my god oh my god oh my god i'm gonna
shoot it shoot it shoot it shoot it oh
my god
[Music]
oh my god oh my god shoot it shoot it
what did i get it
what the hell oh my god no no
no no no
no no what
the hell
was that what is that bench you just
gonna say dead banshee and expect me to
know what that means
that banshee baby that banshee the dead
banshee baby
dead fancy [ __ ] oh god no no no no no
no god i am in the middle of something
oh my god please ow ow ow ow ah
okay i i guess we're good
okay guys did you see uh there was a
thing in here did you just see that
did i just see that by myself hey bud
how you doing
hey good to see you anyway i got to cook
some meat um yeah just do what do you
want
hold the thought hold the thought hold
that thought uh and also i'll be here
i'll be right back hold that hold the
thought hold the thought
okay take that that that that and that
no not the scrap metal thank you i'll
take that that
this crap metal
thank you okay i'm fine
i'm totally fine i need to reload it's
got one shot but you know
to reload why not splurge a little
that was terrible by the way the doors
did basically nothing
is that just going to come for me now
for all time even if i go to the other
safe houses that's going to be the life
that i have to live is that what i'm
have to deal with because that was
horrible
i don't know what the banshee was but
why all of a sudden oh hey by the way
here's something that's gonna scream
your head off and make babies in your
house
thank you just what i wanted and was
hoping for
man surviving each night is just gonna
be a bit more difficult now
all right challenge accepted i guess
molotovs would be great for when the
babies come out
almost too easy they didn't think to
make this any more difficult
they just made it even easier oh those
silly
silly
people if they even are people anymore
which i
doubt they are take this shiny stone
i'll take
small killer and i guess the long
barrel that is kind of a thing that
apparently i need
i'll take it i don't think the wood
cause holy hell
i'm hungry i sure am starving
okay that'll do for now thank you thank
you trade man thank you trademan
i don't know when i'm going to be able
to get the thing that's necessary to
make the upgrade
but man this is this this place is uh
no joke this place is not no joke
all right that should be enough for now
um where did they bro they broke
everything
time to roll out i think there's a
doctor's house up in this nook up top
that maybe maybe i'll be able to see
really that was it i hate
the wren okay already
are you at oh yeah buddy tasty delicious
wood
thank you where was that
okay road oh i found road
i found road let me get out of here guys
i gotta get out of here i found the road
freedom
[Music]
broken tree yeah okay um
hey dude bye dude sorry dude
uh alcohol good rag okay
okay barn ruins
oh boy
that's a lot of dogs i hear the sound of
many dogs
many many many dogs oh yeah
oh many dogs how many dogs
again with the crying
oh no poochy
oh god so many dogs
oh my god
oh god oh god okay okay oh my god
there's so many dogs
oh my god oh my god okay one down
oh my god sorry not really sorry
i guess i could interrupt the charge
yeah i never thought about that before
i guess i could have thrown them i could
have thrown the meat yeah throwing the
meat would be probably preferable
yeah that would be very smart very smart
big smart
big smart on that one would be what that
would be
oh my god oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
take your meat i guess just suck the
meat right at it oh god
oh no i hate all of this i hate this
i hate this there's something about this
game that just wants you to
fight dogs and i just i don't like it
oh my god are they all pregnant oh no
oh no oh no
oh no oh no okay but they're eating the
meat that's probably like a teaching
moment of like hey look
they go for the meat oh crap
oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap
oh crap oh crap oh crap oh crap
oh my god go over the fence
hippity hop
oh my god how did you get there i will
fight you
fight you you ow no please please not
like this
oh my god god please just
let me get one hit ow
oh my god
come at me come at me
give up too soon
there's no point in this meat why am i
even bothering
oh this sucks i should have just
picked the luck
ow god damn it
oh my god no
why am i bothered i there's no point in
the big meet
oh why don't i have my lantern on me
that would help immensely
my goodness oh hey pooches hi
oh oh this is awful
oh good yeah that's that's better
human remains they look stuffed that's
weird
oh this is weird oh this is weird oh
this is this is weird this is weird
this this is weird oh this is weird
oh it's weird oh it's all weird hey wolf
man
hi comrade the greeting sounds like an
angry growl
the wolf makes a quick leap in bouncing
against me with his swollen belly he
puts his paws on my shoulder
he ostentatiously licks his face what a
gift you have given me i notice fresh
blood stains on his fur and feel streaks
of his saliva dripping onto my coat
he leans towards me as if he wanted to
say something to my ear
the wolf squeezes my arms and starts
licking my face once from the left side
once from the right comrade meat his
breath stinks of rot what would i ever
do without you you're not such a
worthless piece of carcass as you look
thanks to you i feel fulfilled
i got my girl my sweet little lady back
hard to believe the same blood flows
through the veins of the [ __ ] who reeks
of chickens
suddenly the wolf sends me back with a
powerful push and reaches into his coat
pocket some object hits the floor
here no need to thank me now since that
part of the deal is behind us i'll help
you recover your stupid key
i'll take you to the doctor's house i'm
sure you'll find some clues on how to
reach his current
out there you two will have a little
chat you will get back what you've lost
and then nothing will keep you from
getting the [ __ ] out of my part of the
woods do you get me meat you'll pack
your bags dive into that stinking hole
of yours and diss a [ __ ] pier
and are we going comrade okay
sure oh now
oh now
right now
oh oh my god
okay this is happening um but i don't
have time for it in this episode so
i guess i'll end it here thank you
everybody so much for watching
what is this going to be like the end i
didn't know i i didn't want it to be the
end
i was i was still playing anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you